do you think sleeping around is
different for men and for women oh gosh
I mean definitely because you can just
go around and do whatever they want then
at the same time we're all human
like I get to a certain degree but it's
different woman [ __ ] 10 boys a boy
wouldn't want to go near her but if a
man did it wouldn't be it would be fine
actually I've interviewed people on this
today 10 is right when you become not
wifey it's like at the 10 to 15 Mark
they're like nah just leave it if it was
a boy it'd be different yes why I think
women I think when they do it it's more
emotional than when men do it I think
when men do it they're more thinking
about how they're going to feel
physically more than mentally and women
are more looking for an emotional
connection rather than something
physical I think that it is different
but it's starting to be normalized that
women can sleep with as many men as they
want to just now I think within the last
five years with the rise of Polly people
are more open to it but I think before
yeah it would be really different it
would be shunned upon and there's how
many bodies there's too many bodies for
you to date someone
I don't think any really like I think
I'm not it should be that wouldn't so do
you think body count matters if if I'm
not gonna lie if I'm being honest if it
was really extensive then yeah I'd be a
bit slightly a bit more cautious in that
regard but I feel you can't just judge
on someone because of their bodycon I
just think that's a bit would you say
your body count
do I even know
the only reason
but no one wants to say it so it's like
if it doesn't matter why don't we all
just say it you would be open to Polly
yeah found that a lot of people here
like are actually like more open to that
how would that work how would it work
yeah like is it like both sides can yeah
I think you just have to have an open
conversation with whoever your partner
is and as long as you guys are in
agreement in alignment then I think that
it works yeah jealous I don't get too
jealous I couldn't
like think about it so everybody has
their favorite hairstyles everybody has
their favorite Barber nobody gets mad
because their Barber Cuts more than one
person's hair right you're just like oh
this person but I'm not I'm not in love
with my barber
some people ever leave the barber I
could I could I mean I can't I've moved
a couple times I go through but what I'm
saying is think about how they're so
that would be the perfect example of
someone who is monogamous to someone
who's not monogamous so someone who's
monogamous they they would not be okay
with you know sharing their person
someone who's not monogamous would be
like oh okay yeah do you think the more
have you ever heard of the Paradox of
choice
so it's like the more choices you have
the less happy you are with your choice
so they say that like the more women
sleep around the less happy they are
with the guy because they've already
experienced like too many I don't think
that that would be a factor I don't know
I think that if you were sleeping with
multiple people you would have a
connection with them I would hope that
someone would have a connection with the
multiple they were sleeping with so I
don't have an answer for that yeah it's
just it's interesting you know that the
longest marriages were when they're both
virgins
yeah I mean it's not I don't think like
I talk to men and women and I think like
the men are like no we should sleep
around they shouldn't and the women are
like now we get to sleep around too but
it's interesting because the people with
the best results are like the virgins
well I mean listen I'm not a virgin so I
can't I know I ain't neither yeah
love this home ah thank you thank you
sleeping around different for men and
for women
I don't know I'll say yes different for
men because men don't feel um uh
attached to the female I guess as much
as a female does that's my opinion I
don't know
she only speaks in German can you tell
me what she says no she said she didn't
understand the question okay
she doesn't want to speak again that's
what she said if you're if you're dating
a girl and she says she slept with 30
men do you care yeah how many bodies is
Too Many Bodies one
I'm joking
I'm joking who's this who's her who's
she who that's why you only count the
good ones no I don't know I would say
now I don't care anymore but like when I
was younger I used to care more yeah why
did that switch for you was it like a
lack of wives no just life experience I
don't know I think it's it gets better
with the age so so now are are you
married no you're looking for a wife you
want to get married at some point no all
right so then then it would have
mattered to you it wouldn't matter no I
don't want to get married do you wanna
do you wanna have kids yeah okay so for
someone you'd want to have kids with
yeah what how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies wow I have to raise the daughters
right
right I'll say I'll say 10 Max 10 Max
yeah yeah that's what I would say I
don't know no that's typical that's like
what I've gotten today dang she said
she's over it
damn she got more than 10. that's what
she said
she's young though 20.
so I'll come tomorrow
I can't marry her then
you want to be experienced and you want
to experience it but women shouldn't
have a lot of bodies no she asked me
like if I would get married yeah how
many men is too many men that's none of
your business it was before you what was
the question here's I'll tell you I'll
tell you I'll tell you but I'll tell you
I'll tell you why like it matters
because if if a girl's a virgin and she
gets married what's her chance of a
happy marriage 80 80 chance that in 10
years she's happy she sleeps with five
men it drops to 25 because the more yeah
it's because like the more the more men
you've been with the more you're going
to compare so it's like it's not healthy
for you
yeah but but a lot but a lot of times
the but the problem is the best doesn't
usually want you because the best guy I
slept with everybody
so it's like experience and get the bit
Yeah but I'm saying like that doesn't
work because the older you get the less
valuable you are to guys yeah because
you they value Purity and youth and so
you've less about the older you get
like like like you said you're 20 like
that's in the dating market like do you
get more matches on dating apps if
you're 20 versus 25. so if I ask what's
the question yeah like what would be
your own Southern how many bodies is Too
Many Bodies I don't really care with a
guy
um I'd say I don't want anything that's
like been on the internet so no like and
honestly I would say if a dude slept
with like a hundred girls like to me
it's like he's never gonna settle down
he's just gonna be in the streets
forever like you can't you can't because
nowadays like if you're in that small
percentage of guys that's sleeping with
everybody what incentive do you have to
settle down matter for you to like make
a decision on if you want to marry the
guy it wouldn't if he wanted to get
married but like to me like early on if
I found that out I would just be like oh
he's never gonna you you didn't like it
like what are the odds that like out of
100 I'm the one that gets him to quit no
I'm not that special I can't what would
you rate yourself one to ten I'll say
solid eight what do you say to the
people that rate themselves as ten what
do I say to them yeah do you think that
10 is perfect do you think Ten's exactly
there's any Perfection yeah I guess I
don't think that there's anyone that
could say that he or she is perfect yeah
that's why I said solid eight so at
eight in my ratio is a ten now I'm just
thinking because so many girls today I
ask they say 10. okay what makes them a
ten I don't know I don't know it makes
them attend if you tell me what a 10 is
then okay that's because I'm unique and
I'm an individual so what makes it
unique that's what I said nothing
okay well thank you
fair enough
no keeping around different for men and
women the problem is we're all a bunch
of slacks
so [ __ ] who you want and we're adults do
we
different like if you're looking for
like long term with a girl like like if
a girl's been an only fans would you
wife her I might marry her stay-at-home
husband Max
stay at home husband Mike let the only
fans six figures I will never go to work
again what if she's bad at all my
friends
what if no one's buying
but unless the secret between me and you
it's a little kinky secret between me
and you the sales aren't hitting but
you've got a little it covers the
Starbucks every now and then
so if you're interested in a girl she
slept with 100 dudes you don't care I
step over 100 women okay let's play the
game what if it's a thousand okay okay
we've grown people when you sleep with
grown people shout out anantis when you
sleep with grown people you're looking
for [ __ ] people sleeping people I can't
be in there doing like figures and facts
you [ __ ] my man but if you step with a
bum he was homeless nowhere to stay I'm
judging you a little bit I'm judging you
just a little bit like it's not about
how many it's who Quality quality you
don't weigh a hundred quality man I must
say I don't want you to have 100 quality
men yeah percentages oh okay it's just
gonna be more 80 of quality 20 he caught
you on a bad day what's your body count
mind your business you said it's over a
hundred I never said that you said that
no you did early I couldn't I didn't
understand that you said if she said 100
people and then you said I've slept with
over a hundred that's what you said yeah
[Music]
let the streets know virgin mics